the model y is quickly becoming tesla's
most popular car it sold around 10 000
units in its launch year of 2020 but
that figure jumped to over 160 000 units
of model y sold in 2021. fans know that
some of the newest ev technologies like
the patented battery are coming to the
model y so let's dive into what exactly
you should expect especially if you're
not caught up with all the buzz around
this car new model y production now when
a car is launched you can expect to jump
in sales figures however a one thousand
five hundred and fifteen percent
year-on-year sales growth is a first in
the automotive market and now in quarter
two of 2022 tesla has already managed to
sell over 53 000 model wise its
popularity is why giga berlin and giga
texas tesla's two newest gigafactories
are starting out by manufacturing the
model wise exclusively the cyber rodeo
events climax in april of this year saw
the first deliveries of the new model y
according to the updated specifications
made in gigatexas strangely elon didn't
reveal any details like specs or pricing
about the new version of the electric
suv however since then i have managed to
learn a fair bit about the new car tesla
has now decided to try out their new
4680 battery cells technology first with
this car which is one of the biggest
features of the new model y but more on
that later back in berlin they are still
making and perhaps going to keep making
the model wise with the standard 2170
cells as they have been since the
introduction of the model y in 2020.
tesla and elon announced that giga
berlin hit a new milestone last week by
producing a thousand model ys in a week
this is a target they originally wanted
to hit a few months ago but they did see
a lot of supply side issues in quarter
one of 2022 which caused this delay now
if they can keep up with these
production numbers per week they'll add
50 000 model wise to tesla's yearly
capacity but the goal is to only scale
up from here and with the addition of
the new model of giga presses scheduled
to take place sometime this year or
early next year there is no reason why
they can't if you're interested to know
more about tesla's new massive giga
presses you should check out my video on
them after this one over at giga texas
is where tesla is going to make the
brand new model y utilizing the 4680
battery cell technology however we have
only seen a few confirmed deliveries so
far mainly to tesla employees who have
ordered their new model wise last year
this is very odd to see especially when
the new model has been listed as
available on tesla's website albeit in
some specific locations only now don't
get me wrong it makes perfect sense that
tesla is taking its time delivering this
new tech and wants to try it out within
the employee pool first but it is still
odd that only a handful of deliveries of
the new model y have been made since the
cyber rodeo event in april and by a
handful i mean less than 50. i would
have expected tesla to have delivered at
least 500 vehicles to have a proper go
at road testing these new model ys
before deliveries began in earnest by
2023 but we still have two more quarters
to go in this year and i am hoping
whatever problem is plaguing the
deliveries of these new models will be
solved in time anyways remember how i
said earlier on in the video that tesla
and especially elon has been very
tight-lipped about this new car well
that's true the only things i've managed
to learn about this new vehicle other
than the fact that it has the new
battery technology is its price range
and acceleration which i'm sure will be
subject to change so here it goes after
the first deliveries at the cyber rodeo
event it was leaked that the new texas
built model y standard will start at 59
990 which was at that time three
thousand dollars lower than the
long-range all-wheel drive version but
this price has gone through some
revision since then according to tesla's
website listing last month they have now
increased the base price of this new
version to 61 990 in all fairness though
due to record inflation and supply side
shortages tesla has increased prices
across board for its entire lineup the
model y long range also went from 62 990
to 65 990 and now tesla is urging some
customers who have other versions of the
model y on order especially from the
fremont plant to downgrade to this
texas-built model with the promise of
faster delivery the new model is also
going to have an epa range of 279 miles
which is 10 miles more than the normal
2022 model y version and maintains its
zero to 60 miles an hour acceleration in
five seconds although i believe tesla
will still offer its software patch
upgrade which will allow you to unlock
the acceleration boost and get it under
four seconds for about two thousand
dollars extra the new model is also
equipped with a few new features like a
magnetic center console armrest and a
parcel shelf other than these not a
whole lot is known about this new
version but not to worry i'm guessing as
people downgrade their existing orders
to this new texas-built version and
tesla starts delivering those models
over this next quarter i'll get more
information about them and you can count
on me to keep you updated on those new
features so don't forget to hit that
subscribe button and click the
notification bell so that you get to
know as soon as i release that video new
model y battery pack but let's talk
about the new battery pack more than any
other features of the new model y i am
definitely more interested in the impact
of the new 4680 battery cell and
structural battery pack and i think most
people are too it's no secret by now
that tesla is having a bit of a problem
with the manufacturing of the new
battery pack in fact elon has made this
very clear in various interviews and
tweets that they are still a few months
away from ironing out all the kinks in
this new battery technology and its mass
manufacturing process however tesla has
already announced the new model y with
this new battery technology and as i've
mentioned above already shipped a few
models out to customers unfortunately no
one has been able to confirm the exact
energy capacity of the new model y but i
heard through the grapevine that some
early texas built model y owners are now
performing some tests one of those early
owners going by spoken reviews on
youtube took the model y for a range
test and charged on a supercharger v3
and here are the results of that test
when it comes to the new energy capacity
the vehicle took a total of 59 kilowatt
hours to go from 10 state of charge to
100 now it's hard to produce a perfect
representation of the energy capacity of
these new batteries but according to
this test that would put the usable
capacity around 66 kilowatt hours in
comparison the standard 2170 battery
tesla model ys have a usable capacity of
75 kilowatt hours so what gives now we
know from inside ev's detective work
that the new 4680 battery pack has a
total of 828 cells that should put the
total usable capacity of this new
battery technology anywhere between 75
kilowatt hours to 80 kilowatt hours so
is tesla software locking these new
texas built model wise just so that
people don't cancel their older model y
orders and wait for this new one it
could very well be true that it's
intentional from tesla however i just
can't be sure until more cars are tested
out on the road as for the charging time
the new model y owner shared the details
of his charging session as well which
came out to be 9 to 50 in 12 minutes and
going up to 80 in roughly 35 minutes
which is excellent he finished the
session with a 100 charge in just over
50 minutes of course this is just one
person's test at a particular
supercharger station however i was a bit
disappointed to see that the vehicle
peaked at 227 kilowatts instead of the
250 kilowatts that the model y with the
2170 cells can achieve but i guess i
have to keep in mind that the
performance of this battery pack may
have been throttled down by tesla so
overall it appears that the 4680 battery
cell has at least a 10 higher pc rate
and average c rate with a 10 lower
usable energy capacity this makes me
super excited for the actual performance
of this new technology once the new
model y version is fully released in
2023 and tesla unlocks the potential of
this new battery pack there are also
insider rumors that tesla has allowed
some employees to test the unlocked
versions of the new model y and it meets
all the things that elon promised to us
during tesla battery day 2020 about the
new 4680 cells either way i am super
excited for tesla to finally solve its
production issues and get started with
the deliveries of the new model wise as
soon as possible but no matter if it
manages to do that in 2022 or not the
demand for these cars has never been
higher and won't go down anytime soon
according to the latest registration
data for the first five months of 2022
new tesla registrations increased by 66
year-over-year to 179
754 registrations so tesla is set up for
some insane growth in the coming years
and the new model y is definitely going
to lead that charge in the foreseeable
future so what do you think about this
new texas-built version of the model y
will tesla's new battery technology be
able to meet the lofty expectations set
by elon and if you enjoyed this video
click the one on your screen see you in
the next one